for years the entire space community has
laughed the lack of progress from blue
origin
and it makes sense considering that's
been two decades since the company was
started
yet they haven't even reached orbit yet
to make things even worse for blue
origin
their direct competitor spacex has been
making outstanding progress with their
new starship rocket
they just completed their first
successful high altitude test
and it's just a matter of time until
they reach mars at this point
but just when you thought that there was
not coming back from the origin
you won't believe what jeff bezos just
pulled out of his back pocket
a few hours ago jeff bezos tweeted that
he has had enough
and that he just went ahead and bought
nasa apparently
the seller was extremely reluctant but
jeff was able to close a deal by making
an offer they couldn't refuse
as we all know nasa has been a money
losing company for basically their
entire lifetime
just last year nasa's investors poured
in 22.6
billion dollars and they didn't see a
single penny in returns
in fact throughout nasa's 69-year
lifetime investors have poured in 650
billion dollars in total
yet still there has been no monetary
return whatsoever
thus it's pretty clear that nasa is an
endless money pit that is on the brink
of bankruptcy
given their financial state even a
valuation of one dollar would give them
an infinite pe ratio
despite this though jeff bezos came in
and offered a solid
420 billion dollars for the entire
company
rumors say that the bidding was intense
and that jeff bezos only beat out the
second highest bidder by a mere 500
billion
now you might be wondering why in the
world would jeff bezos buy such a money
pit
well first of all jeff bezos can cut off
funding for spacex from
nasa but more importantly jeff bezos is
extremely experienced in the realm of
running a money pit
after all amazon's retail business was
unprofitable between 1994
and 2018. you see jeff's strategy
is to outburn the competition the idea
is that if you burn enough money on
offering unbelievably cheap services
one day there will be no competition
left at this point you'll have so many
customers that you can actually make the
unbelievably cheap prices
work it's basically just economies of
skill but
on jeff's level and it looks like jeff
is not wasting any time in implementing
these new business fundamentals
into nasa you may have heard that nasa's
new sls rocket isn't the most
economically friendly
as it is expected to cost 2 billion per
launch
meanwhile elon musk is planning for
starship to just cost 2 million
per launch many elon musk fanboys have
been making memes about how spacex can
launch
1000 starships for the price of just one
sls launch
jeff bezos has been watching the drama
from the sidelines for quite some time
and he is determined to shut up the
fanboys offering sls for one and a half
or one million
itself would have been sufficient but
jeff bezos really wanted to make a
statement and give the middle finger to
elon musk
so he went ahead and reduced the price
of an sls launch down to 69
and 420 cents jeff bezos went on to
boast that an sls launch could be had
for the same price as tesla short shorts
he was also not shy and pointing out
that nasa could now complete
over 28 000 sls launches for the same
price as just one starship launch
after seeing this string of tweets from
jeff bezos elon musk fired back claiming
that two people could play this game
elon musk asserted that spacex was not
only going to reduce their launch price
to zero dollars
but they were going to actually pay
customers 69 and 420 cents to conduct a
launch
this way commercial customers could go
ahead and buy some tesla short shorts
right after the launch
at this point elon thought that he
decisively won the battle
but unfortunately jeff was expecting
elon to do this all along
right after elon fired back jeff pulled
out his ace card
you see nasa wasn't the only acquisition
that jeff had made
he had also bought the entirety of
toyota volkswagen
and general motors now you might be
thinking that these purchases are
worthless in fighting tesla
as these guys are slow legacy automakers
who are struggling to transition to
electric
but here's the thing jeff bezos has no
intention of actually transitioning
these automakers to electric
rather jeff is simply trying to leverage
the manufacturing power of these
companies to squeeze tesla
electric vehicles have really gained
popularity over the past several years
as tesla has continuously decreased
entry price of their evs
as a result the price of evs and ice
vehicles has become more
and more comparable which has caused
many to make the jump to evs
jeff bezos however is looking to
reintroduce the price gap between evs
and ice vehicles
jeff bezos isn't quite offering vehicles
for free but he is making vehicles
complimentary
if you're a prime member this is awesome
for the vast majority of people
and will cut out a significant portion
of tesla's revenue but what about the
people who really value autonomous
driving
maybe they have a one-hour commute to
work every day
so they're going to buy tesla due to its
self-driving features
well jeff bezos has thought about this
as well
on twitter jeff bezos admitted that he
has no clue how self-driving works and
that he has no intention of figuring it
out either
instead he's offering a personal
chauffeur along with each complimentary
card to compensate for the lack of
autonomous software
this eliminates the problem of getting
people to buy a nice vehicle and the
problem of autonomy
however there is still one problem that
jeff bezos is facing
which is manufacturing even with toyota
volkswagen and general motors jeff can
only push out about 30 million cars per
year
considering that amazon has 126 million
prime members just in the u.s alone
it'll take amazon for years to produce
enough cars for just their us prime
members
and that isn't even taking into account
the recent influx of prime members
apparently amazon's prime membership
grew 15-fold after this announcement
so they're going to have to fulfill
quite a few orders in order to
compensate for this influx
jeff bezos has opened the amazon fba
program to all automotive manufacturers
except tesla this includes crowd
favorites like bmw
mercedes rolls-royce and of course
amazon basics
even with the help of these
manufacturers though it's going to take
quite a while for amazon to fulfill
billions of automobile orders
jeff bezos does have a temporary
solution for this as well
but his proposal has received a bit of
mixed feedback
as we all know amazon has an extensive
logistics business
nowadays amazon is able to even offer
one hour delivery in many places
jeff bezos hopes to leverage his immense
logistics power to offer a new mode of
transportation for his prime members
we've all heard of public transportation
and private transportation
but have you ever heard about prime
transportation if you're willing to sit
in a box and have a prime membership
jeff is going to ship you anywhere in
the world for free
in less than one hour haters have
suggested that this is dangerous and
that will likely see a lot of
concussions and broken body parts but
jeff bezos has promised that human
packages will be handled just like
fragile shipments
jeff bezos has also promised that
international shipments will have an
extremely smooth flight experience
considering all of these stellar
offerings from amazon it really does
look like elon musk is trapped in a
corner
most of the major investors in spacex as
well as tesla have been dumping their
stakes
google for instance stated that they
believe that the future of spacex is as
blinding as google glass
bill gates weighed in suggesting that
amazon's entry into the transportation
business
is going to be worse than microsoft
entry into smartphones those really are
quite strong statements
meanwhile michael berry seems to be
having a crummy day as well
he just cashed in on a 96 roi on his
tesla short position
but he's disappointed as he could have
squeezed out a bit more juice
he covered his short position when tesla
stock hovered at 25 a share
since then tesla stock first dipped to
4.20 cents after amazon announced prime
transportation
as for amazon stock they're not having
the best of days either
but since amazon has greater tangible
assets than tesla
they have held their value a bit better
stabilizing at 90 a share
considering all of this it was clear
that the race between jeff bezos and
elon musk was simply a race to the
bottom
whoever ran out of money first would
lose the game and the other would jack
up prices and claim the entire market
given that jeff bezos was in a much
better financial position after their
respective stock crashes
it seemed like jeff bezos had all but
won the game but this
is when things would get a lot more
intense surprisingly
russia and china would decide to throw
their hats in the game as well
seeing that this was the perfect
opportunity to take down nasa once and
for all
russia and china would join forces with
elon musk
meanwhile seeing that this was now a
political battle the us
europe and canada would back jeff bezos
for a few hours
it seemed like we were heading into a
brand new space race centered on putting
people
on mars but six hours after the fiasco
started
edward makuka nicoloso would tweet a
video confirming that zambia
had just landed humans on the surface of
mars
you see while the us and russia were
distracted with the space shuttle and
the international space station
zambia never stopped trying to put
people on mars
and today zambia had won the race did
you guys expect such a turn of events
comment that down below also drop a like
if you guys are excited for the future
of zambia on mars
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions illogically conspired
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one
[Music]
you